thank you very much my name is Danny
O'Brien and I'm the international
director at the Electronic Frontier
Foundation some of this requires an
explanation of our viewpoint and so I'm
going to spend a little bit of time
talking about the ef-s role and I'm also
going to talk a little bit about the
history that Andy's described because I
think that it is very tempting whether
you believe those adages about the
regulation free internet or you didn't
to assume that what we are facing right
now is is a profound change or a novelty
and in fact this sort of relationship
between regulation and technology and
regulation on the Internet is something
that has been ongoing all the way
through this and rhetoric on both sides
would rather attempt to convince you
that the nature of the relationship is
predetermined but in fact it's always
been a contested space and what succeeds
and what doesn't what is a threat and
what isn't a threat has only really
emerged after time and time also has a
way of encouraging people to forget
forget the past and also forget to how
we got to the place that we are now so
I'm going to spend a little bit of time
talking about the early days of the
regulation of the internet and what we
can kind of conclude about that a little
bit of conversation about maybe what
we've forgot in the excitement of
victories and losses and also perhaps
what we forgot simply because either we
believed our own rhetoric or the
rhetoric of others sort of predetermined
what we expect now the Electronic
Frontier Foundation was founded in 1990
which is very annoying for me because
for almost all the time I've spent there
I've had
a an on multiple of ten years in which
to describe how long it is I'm in one of
those moments now where I can tell you
it's 29 years old and that's sort of
annoying right because like first of all
it starts with a zero so it's probably
thirty years old if we really think
about it and I can't give it a nice
round number to give it some sort of
historical historical force or even
hysterical force but it has been around
since 1990 it was formed in the early
days of the recognition that in
particular telecommunications technology
digital telecommunications technology
was going to have a massive effect on
people's lives but also people's civil
liberties so the e FF was always sort of
sat in this this interesting area that
we're kind of going to discuss right
between the law between activism which
can establish new norms and new ways of
thinking about the law and technology
and in particular what we try and do is
preserve or expand some of the values
that we kind of tend to embed into human
rights or civil liberties so that those
will at least be preserved as we
transition into a new environment that
they're mediated through technology or
at the very least it doesn't get more
restricted that we don't we don't break
the open society in our attempts to cope
with the change that new technology is
providing 30 years is a long time but
it's it's it's it's sort of it's a sort
of an interesting thing I think that
maybe many of people here will recognize
about technology and this set of
technology is that people are constantly
worried that they've missed the
revolutionary moment right that they've
come in and like we've had 30 years and
now the internet is settling down and we
don't have a room to change and the
technology has achieved all of the
radical change it's going to achieve or
they worry that it's sort of
accelerating and it's sort of
incomprehensible well I mean I think
we're lucky in a sense that we're living
in the first a hundred years
of the transformative nature of digital
technology in computing right that where
we're still within a certain number of
decades between ours and you know John
MacArthur's work on Lisp or the nature
of transistors or the nature of a a
global shared protocol for digital
communications but all of those things
kind of stack up over the last 50 60 70
years and I still think we have at least
30 years or so
of trying to work out how all of these
thick things fit together and how
quickly they're going to change and like
my model for that is usually and I hope
that the camera still manages to catch
this this will be recognizable to a
bunch of you this is Stewart brands pace
layers of society right where you have
nature culture governance infrastructure
and then at the top here sort of
commerce and at the top fashion okay and
these are these are going at different
speeds in society and you have fashion
and fashion is sort of all over the
place and it's just changing constantly
Commerce which is under a lot of
pressure to rapidly change
infrastructure which is often created by
Commerce and then sort of stabilized
potentially by governance and then
eventually you have governance which has
to sort of maintain all of this stuff
and then laws can sometimes influence
culture but culture moves pretty slowly
and eventually nature is kind of the
bedrock nature doesn't change at least
in our experience as quickly as these
other these other aspects and so when
people think about how law and
technology interact there's always this
sense that if if the Internet is sort of
this merging of Commerce of
infrastructure then-governor to always
get
chasing the change in that area and
that's part of the rhetorical sort of
language that that that only describes
right where you just say you know
technology is changing so quickly in the
internet is so big and broad and crosses
all of these borders that regulation and
governance is never gonna catch up this
is sort of a very blurred set of lines
right there are some times where culture
does get ahead of governance and there
are some times when you know there's a
radical revolutionary change in
governance that that transforms all of
these as well and it's almost like they
occasionally sort of shift in lanes and
when I look at this I always think of it
because maybe I've been living in San
Francisco a little bit too long as a
kind of seismic map right but
occasionally there are these huge
pressures that develop in the nature of
governance that governance is perhaps
failing or being seen to fail and it
sort of stuck in a particular mode of
governing and eventually that pressure
builds very very quickly and it sort of
lurches ahead so even if governance has
been moving very slowly sometimes it
makes a huge jump and that jump can
affect culture it can affect
infrastructure and commerce and it can
affect how technology advances right and
we always sort of assume the technology
is is is deterministic in nature right
that once we do we're discovering the
nature of technology and if one person
didn't discover it than someone else
would and the nature of that
technological rollout is is is fixed and
this this this isn't the case right that
there are many times and places where
how technology is governed can affect
its ramifications so given that I'm just
going to talk a little bit about what
the backdrop was
to the early internet laws and then I'll
zoom very quickly to talking about like
the set of laws that we're facing now
and I'm just of doing this really
because some of these laws will seem
insect right some of these laws will
seem to all of areas like they couldn't
work that it's ridiculous to even
propose that they could work and they
would require a huge amount of the
restructuring not only of existing
technology but of future technology and
while all of those things are true
they're not necessarily positions that
everybody else holds and the lessons
that you might have embedded in your
head either because you've experienced
all these previous eras in Internet and
technological governance or you just
have this as a backdrop to what you
expect law enforcement and regulation to
do doesn't mean that it can't change and
it can't change in a revolutionary or
earthquake like way so let's cut back to
the 90s when all of that language about
like the internet can't be regulated
because it's too big or it can route
around censorship it can and and it's
it's borderless and can't be contained
by simple law so even as that was going
on there was a backdrop and in fact a
lot of that rhetoric was the response to
at least a couple of very determined
attempts to manage and control how the
internet operated and one of those well
as the Telecommunications Act of 1997
but the one that people sort of if they
do remember
by this name there's a Communications
Decency Act and I'm not gonna write it
all out but the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act so these were both took
place in about 1996 to 1998 so very
early days of the internet and both of
these were products of attempts to
create an Internet in the image of what
went before it so the communication
Decency Act was part of the
Telecommunications Act of 1996 and it
had kind of two spokes to it but the
primary spoke of it was a restriction on
what could go on the Internet the idea
was that you would only be able to have
content on the internet that was
publicly viewable that was safe for the
children if you had adult content of any
kind so that's and that's not just sort
of pornography but sort of a material
that might be shocking to a child new
stories personal recollections LBGT
content in some in some jurisdictions
are the kind of shocking imagery then
you would have a legal compulsion to
lock that down and have some sort of
like adult check on it and this this
this really models sort of the media
that existed before that right like you
would have voluntary or not films that
you would that would be 18 or over and
the there would be an expectation even
if you published a magazine that if that
magazine had to add all content that you
would you wouldn't you know move it up
and down the shelves libraries might put
restrictions on this stuff and while the
United States was probably an outlier in
the amount of content it tolerated to be
viewable by everyone that was largely
something that was fairly recent
historically that that had come out of a
very recent struggle over what it meant
to what the First Amendment had meant
and what free speech meant so again one
of the things that I want to kind of
out here because we are talking about
the nature of borders and we are going
to talk about like what a global into
that looks like that the United States
is not particularly exceptional in any
of these sort of extremes and the
position it holds moves around as does
all of these other states if you had had
the internet starting off or kicking off
in 1950s the idea and the model of what
free speech might mean on the internet
would be radically different from an
internet that emerged indeed was someone
created by the free speech advocates and
activists of the late 1960s right that
the 1970s was a period of extreme
transformation and the legal
understanding of free speech and and
some of the ways that we view the laws
around the internet and speech came out
of that particular moment rather than
some sort of eternal truth of the
founding fathers
so the Communications Decency Act had
this provision and it passed rate that
became the law and so this very much was
sort of the regulatory model that people
expected of the Internet and the
Internet at the time was already an
international network
it was prey down predominantly and
dominated by the United States but you
know I was trying to get to it in the
United Kingdom very very complicated set
of begging and borrowing University time
and trying to do communal modem links so
that we could buy a cable that would go
all away across the United to the United
States but it was it was spreading right
you know there were there were there
were terminals in in Russia there was it
was it was connecting across the Pacific
so this was in some ways one of these
first attempts to create a global law
for the internet and it was in a very
American law right the very fact that it
has this sort of idea of decency meant
that well under this this internet
nudity was probably going to be one of
those
that wasn't permitted into this if you
have a German internet then you would
probably have a very different set of
things that were decent or indecent and
then you have the DMCA and the DMCA it
was something that was contingent and
came out of the industrial sectors of
the United States in the 1990s the
United States soft power in many ways
comes from its disproportionate size of
its media industry and there was a
growing feeling particularly in the
terrifying extra sensual threat that the
United States was experienced from as it
turns out Japan a lot of people worrying
about what the United States was going
to do in the face of the inevitable
domination of this tiny island just off
the coast of China and one of their
reactions to this was that they were
going to become less of a manufacturing
base and more a intellectual property
country that basically the United States
core value would come from IP services
microcode microcode movies and pizza as
Neil Stevenson wrote at the time right
so and with that backdrop it was very
important that this emerging digital
communication system protected and
preserved the intellectual property of
these sectors and so what you had in
there is like a series of papers that
were written that said okay whatever
this information superhighway is going
to be it has to enforce intellectual
property and so this vision will lied on
a very different idea about technology
than I think that we're familiar with
now this posited very strongly that
everybody is laptops everybody's devices
everybody's computer any node on this
internet would be constantly monitoring
for infringing copyrighted material
would detect it and I've deleted or let
the authorities
and this is one of the first times where
I hear something we're just describing
this kind of sounds insane right like
the idea that any part of this network
that had like content that you hadn't
originally got a very explicit license
from the rights holder before you could
use it was I would sort of just shut
down if you try to do this kind of thing
seems both technologically impractical
and actually kind of I used them we all
over used the term or William but
certainly some are authoritarian that
you would have these systems in place
and the the the passage of the DMCA was
also kind of rocky this proposal was
originally put forward and failed to get
through Congress in the early 90s and
therefore its proponents both within the
Clinton administration and without it
actually having lost the sort of
democratic debate of this circumvented
the u.s. democratic process and went to
the World Intellectual Property
Organization the sort of transnational
treaty organizations and drafted a
treaty with a set of the things that it
needed in order to achieve this vision
and then brought it back to the United
States and says we've signed this treaty
we now have to enforce this in law and
the Digital Millennium Copyright Act was
that law some of you may be familiar
with like a couple of its provisions the
first one that people are kind of often
familiar with is is DMCA takedowns right
so DMCA takedowns means that there's a
special fast-track process for removing
content from from the internet if what
you're doing is is is pursuing a
copyright claim so other content
is you have to go to court right you
have to actually make some argument to a
judge as to why this person should shut
up about what they're saying DMCA
takedowns mean that you can actually
directly go to the hosting provider of
that and say you have to take that down
there is a nice it is about that that
that particular ability is sort of
carefully cabined with a bunch of
systems that are attempting to protect
kind of against abuse with my EF F hat
on I'll say that we don't feel that
those are sustained like that those
protections don't really work but the
important thing here is that IP has this
at a privileged position on the network
in terms of legal frameworks the other
part of the DMCA is what some of you may
know as the DMCA 1201 provisions and
what these do is they give a sort of
privileged position to copyright
protection technologies and this is
super interesting because this actually
kind of bleeds out from just the
maintenance and enforcement of laws on
the Internet
because what the DMCA 1201 does is it
says that on the internet or not
I can't traffic in a thing that will
break a copyright control and there are
criminal prosecutions if I if I if I did
that if I if I try and sell you or even
give you a thing that lets you get
around the copyright for Netflix systems
or any other digital rights management
system DRM system I'm committing a crime
but I can also not and this is the
wording of the of the law I can't even
tell you how to do that so for instance
in the early years of copyright
protection there is an attempt to create
a copyright protection around CDs and
compact discs for those of you remember
Kahn practiced this particular
protection system was by passable by
using a marker and just drawing around
the the edge of the the compact disc and
we were in this sort of situation where
you may have to delete that because I'm
allegedly I'm not a lawyer this is not
legal advice
all my friends lawyers of the AFF but
they get very nervous when I say these
kind of things but that you could at
least make some claim that that is a
violation of the DMCA and this sort of
hits into a couple of other kind of
interesting aspects of this right which
is that what we have in this sort of
area so what what what what resolved in
what works and what didn't in this
environment
well the first thing that happened in
the communication Decency Act is most of
it was viewed as unconstitutional in the
United States right so the CDA was
mostly thrown out because the ACLU and
the FF went to the courts and said this
is a violation of the First Amendment so
at least the decency part of that sort
of vanished and we can talk about the
bit that sort of remained in that but
but I'm sort of juggling all these balls
and I want to quietly get them all
together in the DMCA system the DMCA
system continued to exist but there are
actually a bunch of things in the DMCA
that you see the echo of some other
kinds of laws and we don't talk about
those so much in the DMCA because we
sort of feel that like they just don't
work as laws and that is tech mandates
so the DMCA actually has a bunch of
things that kind of look if you squint
at them as tech mandates which is to say
that they are requirements that you have
to use a particular technology or you
are forbidden from using another
technology the tech man date that we see
existing in this is the tech mandate of
you
traffic or sell or use anti
circumvention technologies right like
you cannot that that is just a business
model that no longer is it is this you
cannot do that there's also a few other
ones that that are kind of more moribund
there's 1201 K which talks about in huge
detail what you can and can't do when
you build a video cassette recorder and
it talks about how you can't use you
can't have a gain control on it because
what was happening was that people were
trying to create anti copying systems in
video cassette recorders and the way
they were doing this is they were kind
of minimizing the I think it was the the
vertical hold signal the sync signal
which means if you made a copy of that
then that would probably get disappear
into the noise and you would lose the
heart the whole right so the colors
would be screwed and you would rotate
right and what people doing was getting
around with that by just like upping the
game so that the signal would be and so
we're gonna stop that we're gonna ban
that forever
that is the bohtan technology and what
happened was is that tech mandates kind
of ran into the First Amendment right we
got into the situation where tech
mandates which actually if you think
about it technology more broadly are
often the bread and butter of of laws
right you say you can't use this
particular kind of concrete right you
you must use this kind of word in this
kind of proportion to build building
Subway's they fall down mandates like
this sort of exists or things that
politicians could compare and look at
and say well why can't we do this in
this space and a lot of the 90s was
spent kind of trying to both explain in
practice and and and in rhetoric like
why this didn't work and the biggest
argument was that we're not in the world
video cassette recorders anymore and the
dividing line between
a technology and rolling out a
technology and just talking about the
technology talking about code and
implementing and rolling it out were
collapsing and this kind of came under
the idea of code is speech right this is
the again this is the the value as it
were that boiled this down and again for
those of you who sort of know the
history code is speech was sort of a
fundamental fight that we had because
one of the technologies that the US
government wanted to prohibit was strong
encryption and strong encryption public
key encryption is where you can think of
it as a technology you can also express
it in a few lines of mathematics right
you just you just you say your hand in
your piece and you can spell out the RSA
algorithm and maybe you compete in it
but you certainly can't stop people from
spreading that information unless you
want to prohibit speech within the u.s.
judicial framework we have some pretty
strong arguments about this right and
the easiest way that we can convey those
arguments is by saying the code is this
thing right we have some protections in
the First Amendment against prohibiting
certain forms of speech and code is one
of those things like algorithms are one
of those things and we sort of succeeded
so the attempt to prohibit the export of
strong encryption by having it classed
effectively as ammunition in the United
States some export laws eventually
became kind of a dead letter right it's
not actually off the statute books there
are kind of prohibitions around the use
of encryption in the same way as there
are prohibitions about exporting
superconductors or
sorry super computers or even particular
kinds of centrifuges right the
encryption and certain kinds of software
in that category but the understanding
is that the strong encryption is just
something that you can't control the the
export of or even people talking about
it and I just came from the blockchain
conference where everybody's super happy
talking about these things and no one
has like a bust in and attempted to
silence them so so this is sort of Allah
that the the backdrop that we have now
no tech midnight no tech mandates coded
speech and I would sort of roughly say
coded speech and I would roughly say
I've kind of skipped a bit here on on
the Communications Decency Act but I
think there's a sub 1 which is like sort
of no censorship right like the idea of
regulating speech on the Internet is is
certainly seen as a somewhat difficult
and a space where we're regulators trade
very carefully you saw that for instance
what three or four years ago maybe
longer actually maybe five years ago
with the fight over SOPA PIPA
right which was an attempt to create a a
government mandated censorship system
again to protect rights holders
copyright having this sort of primacy in
the United States governance system and
following a huge protest about that this
this this line was sort of established
the point of doing all of this
explanation about what has happened in
the past is that these things are
contingent these are things that were
fought for and and were successfully
either defended or sort of created right
they were they were they were that there
are a set of frameworks that
where we both kind of explained that
this is a value that we kind of want to
defend we explained that like if you try
and get around these things it will just
turn out to be kind of impractical it
just won't be good governance and also
this idea that it might be it might just
be impossible right it might just be
that we're dealing with technology where
censorship is really really not not
possible and that like we have to think
of code as speech because we can't
discriminate between the two and there
no tech mandates because if you try and
have a tech mandate that'll be out of
date within a couple of years and and
also it's sort of a weird thing to try
and introduce into an environment where
people can go from thoughts into
implementation without having to go
through some sort of industrial process
where they get a stamp if they've done
all the right things they can just go
onto the internet and do it so all of
these are sort of tied to the technology
but they're also sort of connected to a
almost a kind of agreement between
regulators and their technical advisers
about what is practical and what is
popular and unpublish all right so the
funny thing like this is like the
beginning of the Lord of the Rings
movies like some things get forgetting
forgotten over time and well we sort of
have this in the back of our heads we've
sort of forgotten that these things are
contingent and can be changed at any
time right some of this is to do with
perceptions about the technology right
some of it is to do with values right
some of this is to do with the fact that
we just think that these things are
worth defending and some of them are to
do with where politicians decided that
this fight is no longer worth it like
what is the that the political
capabilities of what they're doing and
now we're entering into a time where
this stuff around has been kind of
around long enough for people to look at
it and just assume that it's the way the
world is but we now have a new
generation of law makers technologists
general public this sort of going well
why I mean why
who who came down from God and said that
these things should be the case right in
particular the political environment has
changed all around the world and some of
these things were almost none of these
things have sort of like been burnt into
constitutions or been made explicit
they're all utterly implicit assumptions
that are ready to be challenged and and
we've seeing them now being challenged
and I think this is one of those cases
where regulators are sort of ahead of
the technologists because as
technologists we don't have to think
about this this is the backdrop of our
lives right whereas actually this is the
stuff that the emerging politicians and
the general public are going this we
could do this why not so again I would
say I just came from this blockchain
conference and I was listening to Vita
Lake boo Turin who is the founder of and
creator of etherium which is one of the
major sort of broad chain technologies
and he was being interviewed by Tyler
Cowen
and at one point he just said in this
very far away way well you know all over
this technology is mediated by by what
we know about what is permissible and
what isn't and you know we know that
code is speech and we know that like the
Internet is permits anonymity and this
means that the following things happen
right and I'm sitting there and you
can't like yell at the television set or
the radio station where you have
podcasts when you're listening to a
podcast so I guess I just looked like a
crazy person on the street but I was
saying you know these are contingent
this does not have to be this way and
what I mix gonna do is talk about the
laws that are challenging this kind of
thing and trying to give a backdrop
because the people arguing for these
laws are still kind of the same people
who were pushed to a stop by these kind
of internal agreements so the first one
I'm going to talk about is actually the
one that I think probably affects
engineers and technologists the most
directly and that's two bills
act now in fact because we can stop them
1 in the United Kingdom and 1 in
Australia the United Kingdom law is
called the investigatory powers act and
in Australia it's the I'm just get it
wrong because it has two A's in it but
it's the access and Assistance Act and
that was passed at the end of last year
so I'm concentrating the investigatory
Powers Act just because this was the one
that we that was first and is already
having the the ramifications I mean the
the the investor powers act is sort of
came as a result of the Snowden
revelations so I have do I have till
what time do I stop is it 5:30 is it
5:30 or 5:45 okay good all right then I
will expand to fill the time available
so the investigator e powers act was a
response to the Snowden revelations in a
very interesting way I'm from the UK and
I can tell you that the passage of
surveillance law in the United Kingdom
follows this pattern the government
tries to get as much surveillance powers
as it can somebody takes them to court
over it the courts say well we can't say
this is unconstitutional because we
don't actually have a Constitution but
this seems to have gone rather too far
so we're going to throw out the worst
things and then the government passes
another law that says okay we're really
mean it this time
and then it gets challenged again the
investigative powers act came about
because everybody suddenly went oh it
turns out you see HQ is doing all these
terrible things isn't that against the
law and the courts said well it's not
against the law but no one actually said
that they could do it
so what GCHQ has to do is to write a law
that says we're allowed to do these
things and if you pass that then it'll
be legal right and the so the US
government said about writing a law to
describe what GCHQ did so that they
could therefore make it legal and the
problem way
of surveillance of the internet which
has been pretty much in the domain of
the intelligence or community since the
90s is that the intelligence community's
job is kind of to break the law right
like the whole point of the intelligence
community is that they're spies they go
into other countries and they break
those countries laws by monitoring them
you know possibly assassinating them
certainly not doing the kind of thing
that the governments in those countries
would like the members of the public to
do so it's sort of like writing a law
that says you're allowed to break the
law and what we've seen in surveillance
law is an attempt to square this kind of
thing is we create artificial divisions
like well you can't break the law in the
United States but you can break the law
anywhere else or you can break the law
when you're pursuing agents of a foreign
power but you can't do it it to American
citizens and every country has kind of
followed that form the problem that they
struck with the investigative powers
bill was twofold one this wasn't this
power and capability is no longer
something that the government can pursue
on its own terms because the infinite
infrastructure is that you know there's
very limits of it that is government
operated most of it is mediated through
private actors so and the difference
between sort of the large private actors
and individual private actors is utterly
blurred this is the thing that we talked
about with the no tech mandate right
that like you may be able to create some
sort of system where you can compel
British Telecom or Verizon to do
something because they're a big stable
industry but when you have you know
Jerry Yang starting Yahoo or Google
operating you know in the Stanford
campus or or Mark Zuckerberg starting
Facebook there's sort of individuals
they're very small fry right and also
like you know somebody on 4chan
somebody's
know that the the dividing line between
you know Bill Gates of one hand and like
Richard Stallman cranking out code
another like the line is not very
clear-cut so so we enter into this
problem where in order to allow the
intelligence community to break the law
we have to work out well how are we
going to commandeer everybody else to
break those laws to the second part of
the problem is that this technology and
we can't we're talking about this
earlier it's incredibly powerful right
if you could conduct mass surveillance
over everybody in your country or
everybody in the world you know where
they are you know what they're talking
about you know who their friends are
then you know that solves a lot of
regulatory problems right like and again
the predecessors to the investigative
powers bill in the United Kingdom stood
off by saying the intelligence community
is allowed to conduct this kind of
surveillance and also you know anybody
other people who might need to use this
well will interpret it broadly and
within a couple of years The Milk
Marketing Board wanted it to be able to
judge Mills local authorities were
saying you know what we have a lot of
problem with people claiming that
they're in school districts and sending
their kids to like the good school where
in fact they live somewhere else why
don't we just conduct a sort of mass
surveillance program and then we'll be
able to sort out that problem like mass
surveillance solves allegedly almost
every problem that a government has
that's why these Germans spend a lot of
time creating a Stasi right it's it's
it's it's it's very powerful and the
only thing that stops it is in fact that
like the general public will be
extremely annoyed if the police could
come in and kick down their doors and
just go through through all of their
belongings and we can do this for secret
so they need never know it's great so so
that's the other problem here right as
as soon as you reveal that the spooks
and the spies have this incredible power
and we're okay with that everybody else
wants a piece of the action
so the investigatory powers act solve
this in the following ways first of all
it allowed this power for a huge wave of
government and secondly it created a
requirement on technologists to comply
with these demands so basically any of
these bodies can give a technology
company a order to say you have to help
us and this is the bit where I sort of
really emphasize that I'm not making
this up in the provisions of the
investigative Powers Act there's a
special provision that says and whatever
they tell you to do that's legal so and
this is get around you know awkward laws
like the data protection laws or privacy
requirements or the laws that kind of
prevent the ordinary members of public
spying from on other ordinary members of
the public that's all out of the window
because now you are the spies and the
other reason why they had to do this
right is because of this whole no tech
mandate problem right this whole problem
of anyone could have the power to both
spy on a lot of people or stop people
from spying on a lot of people so
there's a person Moxie Marlinspike who
is the primary progenitor I would say
it's probably not the primary author of
signal and signal it's like what's
happens a communications instant
messaging system and it has the
attribute that it's it's it's pretty
it's got pretty good strong cryptography
on it there's some interesting stuff
that we can talk about in the QA mots
Eve's just this guy you know Moxie wrote
the code and put it up on iPhone and
lots of people downloaded it he I think
he just left Twitter so he had some
money and some other people gave him
some money so he's still cranking out
the code in a small office in San
Francisco and what this means is is
that everyone who wants to use a secure
encrypted communication systems can
download Marx's code same thing goes for
whatsapp the the protocol that was
developed for signal was adopted by
whatsapp whatsapp is Facebook right
but Moxie is moxie and there could be
any number of Moxie's right so what you
need in a law like this is you need sort
of this ability to kind of say you can't
do this and you can do this to make tell
protect mandates but you have to be able
to do it in a sort of casual basis and
you have to be able to get anyone to do
it they have to be able to break down a
door and say hey stop working on that
blockchain stuff because it actually
promotes that's the sort of financial
behavior that we disagree with them we
need to be able to monitor that so I
need you to write this code in this
particular way and you can't tell anyone
right because if you tell anyone they'll
just start using Max's code or they'll
start using whatsapp or they'll start
using it fearing them right you have to
stop and you have to lie to your
customers this is an incredible sort of
violation not only in there no tech
mandates but also the code is speech the
backdrop of this whole thing and you
could see this popping up all around the
world so it actually first started the
United States and you certain may of
remember it it was sort of blinded a
little bit because there was also in the
middle of the Trump election period but
in the San Bernardino Apple case right
so there was this big case suddenly
became public where the FBI was asking
Apple were asking in the way that only
the FBI can ask which is with a court
order to rewrite the iOS operating
system on one device right to basically
bypass the protections that mean the you
can't unlock an iPhone and Apple thought
this fought this much harder I think
than the FBI thought that they were
going to fight it because San Bernardino
is it's in California it was like an
awful terrorist attack
and and this particular request was very
sort of narrowly constructed right they
weren't asking for a back door on every
computer but Apple fought it back
because if the government has the right
to say we want you to write technology
in this particular way the sky's the
limit right because the only thing that
means that an iPhone is an iPhone rather
than a spying device that happens to
have you know a camera a microphone a
geolocation device and a barometer I
believe right then is the software
that's in it right if you cross that
line then the government can redefine
the purpose of almost everything that
people have and that's not only bad for
civil society it's bad for Apple's
ability to assert that they're not doing
that right people's anxiety about
technology you may have noticed is
increasing and increasing and the reason
why it's increasing is that they know at
a very profound level that they're
handing all of this private information
to these somewhat opaque organizations
and they don't know what's going on
behind behind the scenes and so the idea
that they not only are they dependent on
the goodwill of Mark Zuckerberg but
they're also dependent on the fact that
Mark Zuckerberg isn't secretly in their
how doing whatever the the government
wants it to him to do and and who knows
which government right like US
government maybe Australian government
UK government who knows right he's under
all of these people are developing laws
to get him to do something makes
destroys the trust between the
technology user and the technologist so
these are kind of the defenses and in in
the San Bernardino case EF f actually
submitted an amicus where we talked
about the First Amendment challenges of
compelling someone to rewrite their code
and we actually took a couple of angles
one under US First Amendment law you
compel speech you can't like tell
someone you have to tell this person
that I'm great right you're like the
government can't do that you have to do
it voluntarily afterwards
and also you in particular you can't
compel someone to sign something and as
it turns out part of the nature of
building firmware for a phone is you you
have to digitally sign it right now boys
the phone's not going to accept it so
these are arguments within the US legal
system so they have this element of
coded speech but underlying that is I
think a deeper principle which is we
can't we there's something really
problematic about compelling other
people to sale right things at the
behest of governments when that can have
almost endless repercussions so so
that's that's that's the first element
of this attack the second part of this
is now happening now that the investor a
powers act that enabled this kind of
behavior and the access and assistant
bill in Australia is passed this is an
attempt really to change these norms
these global norms and you know you've
got two of the five eyes now so this
norm is is gradually shifting the one of
the things that's sort of unbelievable
about this and people we have real
problems convincing anyone to stand
against the investor to guarantee vest
Galerie Powers Act and one of the
reasons was is we seem like extremists
right so we kept so we read it through
and we said we really read this as
saying that the UK government can compel
not only large companies but individual
software and hardware developers to act
as spies and everybody said no I don't
think that's really I mean they're
trying to create a access to data law
enforcement regime that that matches
what they have previously when they
could just go to British Telecom and ask
somebody to what
this is this this is this is the model
that we're trying to achieve but as it
turns out like in order to do that in
this environment you actually kind of do
have to have that power you have to have
that power to rich to reach out to
Richard Stallman and what happened was
well first of all GCHQ said we'll make
this clear in a coat of codes of
practice and then the codes of practice
said actually we do mean they actually
said so when we're talking about Telugu
McKinney communication providers this
does include for instance your local
cafe right so they could go to a local
cafe and say we would like you to run
the software that will install malware
on particular visitors to your to your
cafe and in the australian bill there's
a table i really encourage people to
read it because one of the reasons why
there's more of an outcry about the
australian bill is it's smaller and you
can read it it and there is a table sort
of on the first page the british a much
better than the australians are burying
their stuff but there's a table on the
front page of the australian bill that
basically says yes like we're
specifically talking about persons in
the sense of natural persons rather than
persons that are large institutions and
of course this is applies around the
world we're finally getting to the bit
that the anti sort of talked about which
is that the idea of these is globally
applicable bills right the australians
and the british assert their ability to
change the code that is running on
everybody's machines and again i'm sort
of reaching this at this sort of side
angle because i think the response of
most technologists and most people who
were used to the era when all of these
things are true is to go well that's
impossible they're just not going to be
able to do that australia can tell
australians what to do and screw it I'll
just download and use Moxa's tools right
and like he he will never be able to go
to Australia
so we'll win and we'll use Richard
Stallman's code right because that's
auditable an open source and it's a very
tempting thing to do because that's
ultimately
kind of the reason why we thought that
these rules were cast in stone and it's
also kind of the backstop like when John
Gilmore said the internet roots since
its censorship has damaged and roots
around it it's not a kind of like brave
stand it's a description of the way
things are right it's just going look
this isn't going to work so if this is
your public policy goal you're gonna
have to come up with something different
and we came up with something different
and we're in the environment where some
bits of the DMCA work and some bits
don't and some bits of the
Communications Decency Act were thrown
out as unconstitutional and some bits
kind of operate the way that they used
to but this is all based on this this
peaceable negotiation and that can
change very quickly I'll pick on the
next one and then we'll do Q&A and I can
tell you about all the other terrible
laws that are going on right so the next
one is article 13 and article 11 of the
digital at the copyright in the digital
signal market so this is the return of
IP into the world of controlling and
regulating the Internet if F came into
this pretty late although we've been
monitoring it for a long time this is an
EU directive and we've been monitoring
it for two years but it seemed so insane
that that I was actually relatively
confident that it was never going to get
anywhere we often hit bills where we
just go this would be terrible if true
right terrible if passed right when we
were talking earlier about little
devices that are in every computer that
makes sure that like copyright
violations don't happen
there was actually a bill on the books
in the 2000s to implement this they were
going to be called what were they called
the fridge chips right because there was
after senator
Fricks anyway so so it's a law in the
books and we fought it a little bit but
in the end we kind of went like this is
so extreme that no one
actually gonna support it I'd open 13 an
article 11 are two proposals and I'll go
concentrate on article 30 article 13
says that we've got this terrible
problem with copyright infringement on
the Internet so what we'll do it is that
any service that allows you to upload
content to be shared with the rest of
the world has to put in an algorithmic
filtering and tracking thing that will
come up and say this is copyrighted
content and refused to allow you to
upload it and this will have to be
implemented on every uploading system
that operates in Europe so this is like
historically this is exactly the same as
this sort of 90s IP model of the
internet and you sit there and go okay
well that's not gonna work so like what
you know what what are they doing this
is a stalking horse for some other
proposal that is going to be much more
you know by comparison a much more
realistic thing but it wasn't and it did
in fact get embedded it is now in the
process of being the eyes dotted and the
t's crossed in a negotiation between the
European Commission the European
Parliament and the Member States it's
very close to becoming law and again
this sort of falls into this category of
no tech mandates like well how do we get
into this position well partly we got
into this position because we're still
dealing with people who are relatively
ignorant about what the capabilities of
government are going to be right but
we're also dealing with an Internet and
an environment where they have someone
that they can order around right it's
not to their eyes it's no longer this
question of like we have a million
people around the world and how we going
to enforce this right it's that if we
can target YouTube and Facebook and
SoundCloud right and maybe a few other
big companies then we can probably win
right like if we get all of those people
to comply with this then we have a
revenue stream right we can we can
restrict
right infringement on those sites and we
don't need the rest of it we can just
cope with that so from a political point
of view that seems a very compelling
prospect really you can you can you can
assert your view of how the Internet
should be globally because most of these
companies are about 50 miles radius from
here and in the traditional model of
this and the ones we talked about before
that would have worked because it's the
US government imposing this kind of law
right the US government has successfully
exported the DMCA provisions to the rest
of the world because if you want to get
something removed from YouTube you use
the DMCA provisions even if the DMCA
isn't the law of your country right
because the you know the giggle behave
behaves as though it is the law of the
land in every other country so so they
feel that they can do that interestingly
they're currently and this is whether I
sort of take this very topically
they're currently in this terrible
situation where they're kind of model of
what they want to achieve and how far
they can get is is sort of rubbing
against the values that they want to
replace with all of this so so when we
talk about no tech man a code of speech
no censorship right there are
conflicting and alternative models like
I said there was a model of the internet
that would be protect against
intellectual property there is a model
of technology that says that you will
have to get an agreement before you tell
someone else about this technology or
you would go to jail if you don't do
that and those are viable alternative
value systems and if you believe in
those and you don't believe in these
things then this stuff is just you know
in Connor on on a whiteboard right this
has no place in your value system
well that means is when you're passing
laws like this and somebody says well
you just can't do that because it won't
work the internet will read around
censorship they go well what do we need
to do to stop that from happening
right and so right now we're actually in
this odd position with the copyright
directive in that we won we have four
million people who who basically
implicitly have these values because
they grew up with the internet and they
all wrote to parliamentarians in Europe
and said this is a terrible idea
the parliamentarians tried to stop it
and then they were sold a compromise
right the compromise that have said we
can go into the details but like one of
the bits of the compromises well how
about if we make it so that it only
applies to YouTube and it only applies
to Santa and it only applies to
companies that are like bringing in
twenty million dollars or more of
revenue or have less than say three more
than three million users right and
therefore if there are other parts of
the internet where this is important for
people to be able to just talk then they
can do it there and we can we can deal
with these companies well right now
France and Germany are in this huge
fight because Germany wants to maintain
those principles because you know they
want companies to be able to compete
with Google and and YouTube and
SoundCloud and so forth right they want
to have a vibrant EU technological
environment that can still rely on these
kind of rules and the French are saying
no you don't understand this is a moral
duty right these companies are violating
copyright right and if just because
they're making less than 20 million
dollars doesn't mean they they're not
like you know violating the rules of
intellectual property it's got to be
everyone and the last I heard is that
macron and Angela Merkel are literally
talking to each other to try and work
out what this agreement will be it's a
ridiculous compromise right it you know
if you carve it out that way then all
that means is you've created this sort
of Potemkin village of companies that
are allowed to basically use the
internet and communicate with one out
without this like massive infrastructure
but the moment they poke out their heads
above like basically the point in which
they might be competitive or Google
they're wiped out right like they cannot
they'll have to go actually we can't
take any more people because if we take
any more people they'll come for us and
we'll have to buy the copyright
filtering technology which is course
primarily owned by Google Apple so so we
have this super interesting environment
right now where these values are being
challenged I'm gonna I want to give
people an opportunity to ask questions
because I sort of feel like I've I
walked you around the context to all of
this but I haven't got the meat of what
you really want me to say which is what
how will country is like impose their
viewpoint on on us and the rest of the
world and like which countries are doing
it and so you can ask those questions
and I'll be happy to do it but this is
the this is the environment that we find
ourselves in and this is why it's super
important for technologists engineers to
step up and defend these values because
if we don't we're going to be in a very
different Internet and a very different
tech environment